so excited to get the chance to talk to
you about this show i just finished
watching season one the other night
uh and it is a blast i'm already kind of
clamoring for
more because where they leave that with
that cliffhanger like i cannot i can't
wait
i know it's an aggressive cliffhanger
for the end of season one
um i'd love to take it back to
before
the show even started how familiar were
you with the resident evil franchise
before you signed on i had played the
games and watched the movies so i was
familiar
when did you officially learn who you'd
be playing in the show i'm wondering
what the casting process was like did
you audition for anybody else was there
you know a case of maybe being up for a
couple different roles like how did you
finally end up
playing jade um so the i sort of got the
the email straight away through for um
for jade to be honest with you um it was
under the guise of the title venus
flytrap and i was like oh what's this
this is interesting
read the script and then about two pages
in you see the word umbrella and i was
like ah
resident evil now i know what's
happening here um
and i pretty much uh spoke with the
producers
kind of got an idea of what they wanted
to do with the character with the show
with the ark with the the world of
resident evil because as a fan you know
i was so curious to see how they would
evolve um
the history of that that is the
franchise
um and then i essentially
whacked a scene on tape
of how i thought this character would
approach this world
um
and then the rest is history
i don't think it's any exaggeration to
say you kick ass on this show like
majorly and it's so fun to watch um
but after working on say a project like
charlie's angels i'm curious as to
whether the training process was any
different for you this time around did
you have to approach stunts any
differently how intensive was that for
you i'm i'm wondering how that all was
well first of all thank you
um second of all um actually the
interesting thing about this process
like you say it wasn't my first rodeo in
the uh in the stunt sphere
especially with action
i had to unlearn a lot of the stuff that
i've been trained in because
a character such as the one in charlie's
angels she's
a trained
operative um
very choreographed fight style very
regimented but this with jade she is not
a superhero she's not a trained
operative
so we wanted it to feel messy we wanted
it to feel dangerous
um so we had to unlearn a lot of the
the that sort of
regimented fighting style so we did a
lot of jiu jitsu which is a lot of
grappling
um it's a lot of
moment by moment decision making which
is exactly what we needed for the
character
so that you know hopefully when you
watch these sequences you do feel very
much on the edge of your seat
and it does look a little bit more
disheveled than something that is very
polished there are definitely shots in
this for your character specifically
that look like they are pulled right
from the games i'm thinking specifically
there's a shot i won't go into spoilers
but there's a shot from first person
perspective where jade is like stumbling
around disoriented and i was like this
is a video game
that was something that was so important
to us for the producers um to really
make
you know that feeling from resident evil
feel real in this series
and that's something that even if you
notice it even if you don't you still
get that feeling
um i think that's something that you get
definitely if you're a fan of the
franchise you're kind of in a i would
say uniquely shared position on this
show because you're you're part of a
group of actresses who are playing
one of two versions of the same
character because as we find out in the
show
you know it's set between past and
present with a difference of i believe
it's about 14 years between the two
um i'm wondering how collaborative it
was for you to getting to work with you
know the other actresses and like
especially you know tamara playing the
younger version like were there was
there anything you got to watch from her
performance anything that you tried to
kind of take from her to bring into your
own
how collaborative of a process so i mean
this was an example of you know two
people being cast who really had a
strong grasp of what we wanted to do
with the character
um
we
met for the first time on set in south
africa uh so the chemistry that we had
even though we weren't working together
it was more the sort of um
just a s
seamless streamlined one of those
sibilant words
um
take on
on jade wesker
and it was such a pleasure being able to
watch tamara
on her timeline which is a lot cleaner
than mine
um sort of make the decisions that she
made as a younger jade which informed a
lot of the decisions that she made in
2036 a lot of the traumas that happened
to her in the past and how they carry on
into the present
um
even something as small as her
unapologetic
stubbornness and
sort of fire that she has which then
comes out in moments in 2036 but also
seeing the guilt that she carries
through both timelines um i think adds a
very human and um engaging character arc
for her
one of the themes in the show that feels
so important is family and we get to see
that take shape in a lot of different
ways you know in the past there's
definitely we would say more of like a
nuclear family that's established but
then in the in the future
jade also has her own sense of family
that she has established
which
starts i would say is shattered a little
bit
by the sudden reveal that billy is kind
of still around you know someone who she
had believed to have been gone um
how does that kind of inform her arc
that revelation and how it plays out for
the season
jay does her absolute best
in the past to stand by her sister as
much as possible to the point where you
know it gets her into trouble
and she realizes that and she carries
this responsibility in this guilt like
that i've previously mentioned all the
way up until 2036.
um
obviously the traumatic events of the t
virus and umbrella taking over happens
in those 14 years in between
which lands her in 2036 where
we're in this sort of survival mode way
of of human life she's done her best to
create her own family to try and do the
thing do everything in the best way that
she can
but still
this is the interesting part about jade
is that you also you love her and you
kind of dislike her because there's a
lot of things that she does that are
very questionable she's she's out away
from her family for six months
which is you know with her daughter who
is going through her formative years
whereas she's also out there trying to
solve the t virus figure out a cure for
that and
learn more about the zeros to try and
make the world a better place for her
daughter
so it's a very interesting um mix
between
responsibility and guilt but also this
undying
need to try and um
problem solve on her own
uh she has like an innate need to be
independent and to fix things because
she broke them so aggressively in the
past i personally cannot wait to see
what happens i mean i'm crossing my
fingers already for season two because i
feel like like we said before the
cliffhanger on this season
i have to know what happens and i
haven't feeling plenty more same
i know
i'm sure plenty more fans are going to
be feeling the same way i am all out of
time but thank you so much for taking
the time out of your day to talk to me
about this show i can't wait for
everybody else to to see you in it
because you like i said before you
really kick some ass so
thank you so much of course thank you
you